[Music]
good morning and welcome to wholesome
roots today i'm going to give you some
tomato tips
today's tomato tips are going to be
pruning your young tomato
plants my advice
may differ from some of the other advice
that you've received online
[Music]
i have been growing tomato plants for
over 40 years
literally it was my job as a young child
to take care of the tomato plants
and the very first thing i planted when
i moved away from my mother's homestead
was tomatoes they are my favorite
and so i'm very passionate about
tomatoes there are many myths
surrounding tomatoes and how to care for
them one of the biggest that hurts my
soul the most
i think
is the fact that
tomatoes are often said to have suckers
i'm about to burst your bubble people
tomatoes
don't
have
suckers
what people are calling suckers
on tomato plants is actually
lateral stems
lateral stems produce just as much fruit
as the main stem
there is
no reason that these need to be removed
a true sucker
is going to be
something that is draining energy from
the plant
and this is usually associated with
trees that have suckers coming out from
the roots around the base of the tree
this is not something that we see in
tomatoes at all
so every one of these
suckers
is just something that's going to
produce more fruit so scientifically
speaking
tomatoes don't have suckers some people
might say that when you remove the
suckers you get more fruit but you're
not gaining any more fruit by removing
suckers you actually are going to have
less fruit the fruit may be bigger
because there's fewer of them so the
energy of the plant is going into fewer
fruit
so your pounds of tomatoes at the end
may be close to the same but your actual
number of tomatoes does not increase at
all in fact when you leave your suckers
they're going to grow you far more
tomatoes on the plant and the reason why
this is a good thing to have is because
if you have a bird or a squirrel come
along and take a bite out of one tomato
and it's only one of three tomatoes on
your plant
you've just lost a third of your crop
whereas if a bird or squirrel comes
along and takes a bite out of one of
13 tomatoes you still have plenty more
to harvest no big loss okay now that
i've gotten that off my chest let me
step down off of my soapbox
and teach you about how i do prune my
tomato plants for better health and
better harvest
[Music]
the sky is blue the sun is high
this tomato plant here in the middle is
a little bit on the large size for the
pruning
and some of these shorter smaller ones
are more ideal
so i've been waiting to prune so that i
could make this video and i needed a
good day that i could do that so today's
that day and i'm going to show you how i
do this first off i got a steak to find
my center trunk and make sure it was
facing up so that i could find
which parts of this plant need to be
pruned off
i do prune in the beginning of the
plant's growth i prune everything off of
the bottom foot but right now we don't
have much more than a foot of growth so
it's only going to be a third of the
plant until we reach that foot mark
and that
is about at three feet tall so
everything
that i'm cutting off is going to be
leaves that come off the side
and lateral
stems
not suckers
that come off the side at the joint
between the leaves
and the main stem
tomatoes are vines they are not meant
to have
just one stem they are a vine
so
it is important that you give them that
opportunity to do what they want to do
tomatoes are going to naturally do it
anyway why fight it the reason why i
prune everything from a foot down is so
that there's no splashing on the leaves
that could introduce blight into the
tomato plant from the soil the good
thing is is that these bottom
suckers
or lateral roots
can be rooted so as i trim this plant up
i'm going to put each one of those
lateral stems into a container of water
they will root in that water and i will
have new plants to grow in another area
in the garden it is important that the
pruners that you use are sanitized you
don't want to introduce any disease to
your tomato plants all right so this one
is an ideal size for beginning our
pruning transformation i don't want to
remove more than a third of the plant
from the bottom portion so i'm going to
come in here and i'm going to remove
that leaf
and that leaf
and i'm going to dispose of my tomato
leaves in the trash because i don't want
to carry any blight into my compost now
you notice i left these lateral branches
the reason why i'm leaving these
is because they are so small at this
point that i actually can't really get a
good root on ones that are that tiny
and that leaves us about two-thirds of
the plant total
material of green leaf behind
okay so then we get to this slightly
bigger plant
i'm going to remove
all of the leaves first
that are coming off of that main stem
making sure that i dispose of them
properly
and because i have
a lateral stem
down low that's a good size i'm going to
cut that one off this one is going to
get cut off as well
because it's so low to the ground
and i'm going to
i might leave that one for one more go
but i'm going to remove this leaf above
it so i cut my lateral branch and place
it into water
and while i'm in here i noticed that the
container that i planted
these tomatoes from must have had some
weed seeds in them
so i'm going to go ahead and pull that
and make sure that there's no
competition in my root zone
we want to keep it weed free so that the
roots can develop and grow beautiful
fruit
all right now this one is a prime
example of
letting it go too far
so i'm going to be pruning this one much
more heavily i'm removing
all of the bottom leaves and lateral
growth look at the size of that lateral
stem that will grow a new tomato plant
all of those
nice fat lower lateral stems
will become new plants for us
so look at that
who knew
as you can see i have left
this lateral stem
right about where the first bloom starts
is usually when i start leaving those
lateral branches so this plant does need
to be continued
in proper staking
and i'll save that for another video
[Music]
so now that i've got one bed done
i just have a few more to go
make sure you get those
newly cut stems out of the sunlight or
they will wilt very fast
all right so that's how i prune my
tomato plants i gotta get busy pruning
the rest
as you can see they look beautiful and
healthy as it is and i'm going to
continue to show the progress as we grow
if you have any questions or tips let me
know down in the comments
we'll see you next time on wholesome
roots another fun fact for you
this is a tomato leaf not just one of
these single
leaves on the side here but this entire
structure is one leaf